Ali Italian Kitchen wants to keep your
heart and your stomach full on
Valentine's Day chef bogdon and Eli from
locally are here they're going to show
us how they like to share the love all
year round right of course every day of
course a little more on Valentine's Day
though so a little more on Valentine's
Day naturally so for Valentine's Day I
feel like prefix menus are always 100 to
go that's the romantic date night the
fixed menu that is so let's talk food
first and then we'll get to the drink
what I want you to do is start making
the drink perfect so that it's almost
there once we get to you okay not a
problem let's talk about the menu what's
going to be on menu okay so we brought a
few things with us the first one is our
crab cake it is Maryland Blue Crab on a
spicy remoulade
arugula on top
with pickled peppers and a lemon honey
vinaigrette oh that's I love all those
flavors together and then a grilled
lemon next to it delicious delicious and
the next we have it's a smooth voice I
love this for Valentine's Day and then
this one is a potato puree with a seven
ounce filet okay this is the main dish
this is the best yeah right there two
loves right there come together oh
exactly and then we have a compound
butter made with calibrian peppers
delicious
oh oh some fire a little bit of fire on
it
that's sexy that's hot
and we'll have a lobster tail with it as
well I love it and then for dessert of
course you have to have dessert we are
gonna do a triple chocolate cake so it's
white chocolate Nutella and milk
chocolate
over here over here scoot that right off
right over here so while I find a fork
to get this started I want to talk
drinks because you can't do Valentine's
Day Without a cocktail to kind of get
the mood going get things flowing worse
you know what I'm saying so I always say
that you can eat dessert or drink
dessert in this case you're gonna have
to do both right exactly so well you eat
dessert
this isn't a raspberry Ford roses
old-fashioned for you so raspberry
chocolate
shanky's whip this is delicious
and the raspberry syrup that simple
syrup gets that nice red color to it so
you get that little bit of love right
there for it so amazing okay and while I
taste because that's what I do best here
have there been any fun proposals or
date nights that come out there's a
little Cali there's always at least one
proposal that we have every Valentine's
Day
um this year we we may know more than
one so I love
you guys are great thank you so much
best way to make a reservation for this
effects menu uh either online with us at
locally lv.com or give us a call
702-330-0404 there you go personal
invite okay thank you guys thank you for
having us now Bruno Mars is getting us
also in the